[Music]
hey guys
married people in this room that's me
i'm married wow i feel excluded
sorry conversation well you could fix it
oh yeah no
no no make it happen all right every
time we say this still not used to it
yet n-o-e
that's their couple name in case you may
watch the other video that's our ship
name
all right so did you guys know that
there is one
way to lower your risk of divorce
according to this meta-analysis
published in journal of cons
is it sex is it don't cut her off don't
cut her off while she's talking
behavioral science
no oh i know how is it sex don't get
married in the first place
then you don't divorce that's true
that's the only way to prevent divorce
that is the only way pretend like she's
always right
no so uh this one study
there was a study where psychologists
looked at 174 couples to see how
effective
certain activities were at improving
their relationships
so the researchers divided the couples
into four groups assigning each group to
either
complete the highly regarded premarital
relationship enhancement program
aka prep that's the toughest one uh no
so that's like one group did that that's
what we need to do
another group attended workshops offered
by this program that's designed to build
empathy and compassion
and then the c group everyone take one
of these
the next one one group got by yeah
and somebody's on mushrooms right now
tripping balls in the back and then
this other group got weed because they
were watching movies and discussing the
on-screen relationship depicted
minus the weed that sounds fun actually
that does sound fun okay
yeah minus the weight it's like enter
the doors like go into these rooms yeah
so it's either you go to prep
or you go to the workshop for empathy
and compassion
you watch movies ruby was the most fun
one i know
yeah or you get to be the control group
and do none of them wait what do you
just sit in a room together
no or you just live your life just live
your life and they just study you
yeah as is so what they discovered was
that
the group that ended up watching movies
and then discussing the on-screen
relationships depicted
then like they would end up discussing
their own relationships
they ended up having about the same
success rate as the workshop
people people going okay doesn't that
say like
you don't really need therapy you just
go and watch movies and talk about it
actually netflixing yeah and chilling
they're like hey spend time together
but talking to each other that's the
part of the idea yeah so that's the part
that is the key element here because you
can't just be watching a whole bunch of
rom-com movies and think like oh we're
watching
uh we're watching something depicting
another relationship they actually
suggest
not watching rom-coms because usually in
those movies the couple
it's like a porno no the couple ends up
being together at the end of the movie
those movies don't make no damn sense
you don't get to see the relationship
struggles it's the it's the it's the how
to get
into a relationship but then uh that's
why they recommend
dramas like dramas are the most
effective genre yeah like saving private
ryan
really good drama not for relationships
though a raging bull wait that's not a
romance movie
no what what what would be a casino
that's a good romance movie
pretty pretty he was hella simple for
his girl yeah and she kept
going too yeah yeah yeah that's
realistic right but he [ __ ] loved her
though
i know right pimp guy loved her dude
james woods yeah i don't remember that
movie you got to watch casino
it's really really good i watched it for
the first time two months ago and i was
like why haven't i never seen this
before and
she [ __ ] his best friend i remember
that yeah joe pesci that's my favorite
scorsese movie yeah i always get
that one mixed up with like all the
other gangster ones like good fellows no
i know good fellas for sure because i
watched that one like scarface
i know that one for sure too because
that [ __ ] traumatized me i watched it
when i was really like casino
with what yeah with what uh the other
one analyze this
dude dude casino antonio robert de niro
monologues that entire [ __ ] movie
it's great right that's my favorite
one yeah he narrates
here they're suggesting more films kind
of or like
the the films that were included in that
study were true lies
mr mrs smith and american beauty mr and
mrs smith i can see
yeah yeah so then it's like the the key
element again
is to discuss the on-screen
relationships with your partner and
that's kind of like an icebreaker into
discussing your own relationship
what if we're discussing it as a group
do we all stay together and not get
divorced
true lies is the arnold one right [ __ ]
yeah with jamie lee curtis yeah so all
of these are like
agent spy kind of movies and it's kind
of like can you imagine if we were spies
yeah it's all badass you want to go join
the cia
well american beauty isn't spike oh
that's like isn't he
into he's into his daughter's his
daughter's that's the one with the girl
on the ceiling with the roses correct
yeah i don't think she's on a ceiling
no yeah she won't she's on the ceiling
and the pedals are coming she was laying
in the bed looking up
oh cause i thought she was on the ground
with her hair all out like this
well that's how they shot it and then
the petals because the pillow the petals
aren't
going up yeah what about stiffler's mom
that's true
they definitely shot it like that what
about stiffler's mom though isn't that
the american
movie that's the girl coming out of the
pool right no that's american pie
that's the first tell me how the pool is
uh fast times that really clearly only
remember the women in all these movies
i don't know what else is going on they
were very pretty it was very different i
think as the most
experienced in the marriage department
in this room
i'd have to say that my advice oh that's
you
we all have to listen to joe yeah he's
the most i am the most experienced
he's the expert at whatever the
situation right and you guys don't have
nothing on me
that's true because i have the most
experience in marriage
i think the best thing to do
is to watch porn together oh and then
talk about it
have you guys actually done that i've
never done it you never know
you've never i just imagined that it
would be a great solution really you
never had it i like that you give
advice to that you've never done i've
done that with a chick before though
and it was pretty weird i've done it
it's interesting and our porn
likes are way different yeah i think
that would be the case too that actually
happened with us
there's a lot of men in my porn yeah i'm
not so into that yeah
i don't know if i could get with a gang
bang like like a bunch of guys
doing one girl yeah that's the only kind
i watch and you can't it's hard to talk
feelings when there's like
you know to me yeah i feel like steve
would just be watching me the whole time
and make making sure i don't get turned
on by it i'm like
hey what are you turned on about this
with like all the dicks
oh [ __ ] there's nothing more awkward
than saying you pick
you put something on you're like oh [ __ ]
no and then you put it on and then they
judge you for it right yeah and you're
like
oh i don't really like this i meant this
one never
do that again i've done it what i would
not do
because and so you know how you can
search for it on the television so it's
like
they see your search history so it's big
your neighbors can see through the
window
pretty much and they're like oh no baby
you pick and i'm like
oh you're no no what are you into what's
your weird ass [ __ ]
it just wasn't that per it looked very
different than the person i loved yeah
that ended up happening too
so psychological comparison yeah so i
was like
oh no i already know where this is gonna
go like you're with a black guy and
you're searching five foot asian guy
and then you're just like damn i'm gonna
make him jealous right now right and he
was he would feel so
insecure about what he was working five
foot asian guy who wears merch
yes he wears nikki blades merch
yes long hair coming soon um
yes that was that was i mean i feel like
it's a good talking point you could
totally play around with it if you guys
are
into similar things and explore i think
that it could be cool but relate
but i don't know i don't think you have
to some i mean
or you could do like a roulette kind of
kind of thing like a roulette
roulette you know what would be
interesting you sit there and you're
gonna see who reacts
so you can just sit there and then see
who reacts depending on you're trying to
have a bad night
like you try to have a fight night i
think it could be fun what stage in the
relationship would you be comfortable
with that cause
we lived together at that point what was
that mojo quiz thing it there was a quiz
that like you each fill it out
separately but you like put it in
together and it
it only shows you the kinks that you
have in common yeah
that would be cool that's pretty cool
and then i well when i was doing
it my mindset was like am i down to try
this or like am i curious enough to try
this or like now i've already done
enough of this
i want to try something else and then
like once we ended up comparing it was
like
oh [ __ ] that's pretty cool like it ended
up lining up a lot of stuff
that's cool it all depends though too
because we nikki were just at an airbnb
i tell you guys this and there was like
all this bonded [ __ ] in the room did you
use it
no we what could poo put on to ask this
chap she would have been
the biggest pain in the ass like sub
[ __ ] ever of all time i don't like to
stand you don't want to beat them up
what's a sub [ __ ] yeah what does that
mean like it's submissive
no i mean like what do you mean so like
if i'm if i'm gonna whip her or whatever
the [ __ ] right and
i'm not even into that maybe a better
dom no no i just don't wanna you're just
so that's just not your world yeah i
just don't wanna be her
like i don't wanna she would be like ow
i'll wait my arms hurt like no
that's why that's why even your gang
bang
like the porn that you watch i know you
wouldn't last never do it no exactly and
i try to explain it to you i'm like no i
don't ever want this to happen to me i
just you fantasize about it
yeah i just like watching because it's
like the humiliation
of feeling but i don't have to be
humiliated like that or like go through
all that but i just like to
there's a difference between what you
would watch versus what you would
actually
but i wish that more people knew that
because a lot of guys will
hear that she likes gaming porn or
whatever it is like oh my girl likes his
porn so that she wants me to do that to
her
and so guys try to do porn things to
their chicks and that's not what they
want necessarily
there's guys out there like my girl
loves gangbangs and i love her so i
gotta call my five friends
hey dude can we do this my ex-boyfriend
did that he's like so
which one of our friends would you want
i was like i don't know no one's coming
into this no
or even the come on the face thing all
that kind of [ __ ] that
it just depends on who you're talking to
right and and sometimes depends on like
where you are in your relationship
because there's experimental times where
you're like okay let's give this a try
the early stages
yeah just to be like oh [ __ ] actually
in the early stages that could that
could cause damage like for the rest
because then like why'd you come on my
face if it's not the right reaction it
ends up causing more hearts yeah
yes yeah because you don't trust after
that yeah and it's how you feel after i
think that if you do something and go
too far and then you're able to
be cool after and kind of talk through
like what happened
you can trigger somebody on some [ __ ]
they didn't even know they had problems
with
pops up i cried one time in the tub
after once
something like something was going on
and it did and i was like
nope nope don't like this and it felt
but the person that i was with we were
comfortable enough that after the fact
it was like no
cool like don't do that ever again yeah
but then i still felt comfortable with
i think i became closer to that person
because now we understood what i
don't like and then we talked about it
and then now it's like okay cool we can
still do other things because we were
able to make a pass but that's good it's
all communication
it's all bearing that kind of goes back
don't worry let's do it again don't come
in here
i'm okay taking a big [ __ ] right now
just leave me alone any more minutes
that communication part though is what
they're talking about in this study
again with the whole watching the movies
or a tv show
together and then discussing it with
your with your partner because being
vulnerable and having that open
communication is
really difficult for a lot of people so
then this is a good
outlet to kind of get your feet wet and
ease into talking about your own
relationship when you're
when you're analyzing an on-screen
[Music]
relationship
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you